vor fast genau einem jahr verstrickten
lka fahnder durchsuchungsbeschlüsse bei
christoph metzelder
am freitag gaben die ermittler bekannt
297 kinder und jugendpornografie auf dem
handy des ex-nationalspielers gefunden
zu haben
am amtsgericht düsseldorf erhob die
staatsanwaltschaft gestern offiziell
anklage
darüber möchte ich nun sprechen wird
rainer becker polizeidirektor ade bei
uns im studio herr becker schönen dank
für ihren besuch bei uns wenn wir uns
das ganze mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen also sind wirklich schlimme
zahlen die dort veröffentlicht wurden
trotzdem kann diese tat als vergehen
wahrgenommen werden heißt das also dass
das verfahren gehen christoph metzelder
eventuell gegen eine geldstrafe
eingestellt werden wird theoretisch ist
das denkbar
die derzeitige rechtslage die ich auch
mal kritisiert hatte sah so aus dass bis
zum fall dati die höchststrafe für den
besitz oder sich das besitz verschaffen
von sogenannten kinderpornografischem
material maximal zwei jahre betrug beim
ladendiebstahl dagegen bis zu fünf jahre
und dann nach dem fall dati hat man es
dann um drastische 30 prozent erhöht und
ist auf drei jahre gegangen blieb immer
noch zwei jahre unter dem ladendiebstahl
und da habe ich natürlich auch
öffentlich das sehr deutlich gemacht
dass er das gar nicht angehen kann
sowohl der begriff ist im grunde schon
daneben als auch die strafandrohung denn
pornografie wird meistens ja verknüpft
einfach dass die leute sechs filme
anschauen und bei sogenannten
kinderpornografischen material geht es
bei jedem einzelnen bild um die
vergewaltigung oder andere formen
sexueller gewalt eines kindes das da
nicht einvernehmlich sex hat mit
irgendwelchen erwachsenen und auch gar
nicht weiß dass es ins netz eingestellt
wird und sein leben lang da sein wird
ja sie sprechen jetzt schon an da muss
ich natürlich die frage stellen was
läuft in unserem juristischen system
falsch dass ein mensch der knapp 300
kinder und jugendpornografische dateien
auf dem handy hat nicht direkt in den
knast wandert wir haben bislang wie
gesagt diese regelung dass ihm maximal
drei jahre freiheitsstrafe drohen
dann wird man berücksichtige im rahmen
der frei
richterlichen beweiswürdigung der
richterliche unabhängigkeit dass er das
erste mal höchstwahrscheinlich
aufgefallen sein dürfte
und man wird schauen um wen handelt es
sich und da wird man abwägen und er
besteht theoretisch die möglichkeit zu
sagen in der tat beim ersten mal würde
ich jetzt erwischt haben und so weiter
da lassen wir das mit einer geldstrafe
davonkommen
wie ist denn wenigstens aber in
tagessätzen oder tagessätzen heißt also
30 tagessätze für sie werden sicherlich
weniger und würden genauso weh tun wie
30 tagessätze also 30 tages gehälter von
ihm also solche sachen sind durchaus
möglich
künftig ist jetzt ja geplant von frau
lambrecht diesen tatbestand wo sie mich
sogar fast überholt hatte sogar zum
verbrechen zu machen ja was heißt
mindestfreiheitsstrafe ein jahr
das hat mich aber trotzdem gefreut ich
bin da ja relativ moderat rangegangen
mit meinen forderungen ist ich sagte bis
zu fünf jahre
denn es geht mir ja weniger um sechs
monate mehr oder weniger es gibt mir
darum auch in die sprache und müssen
einfach deutlich machen es ist ein
verbrechen was kindern hier angetan hat
denn ein vergehen gilt als
minderschwerer rechtsbruch in unserem
strafgesetzbuch während verbrechen
sogenannte schwere rechtsbrüche
darstellen und darum ist das ist das
entscheidende
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren